وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش الروسيه
استهدف بصواريخها عاليه الدقه مواقع
عسكريه اوكرانيه في مدينه
ملينتسكي غربيه اوكرانيا كما اعلنت عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 250 عسكريا اوكرانيا في
شرق اوكرانيا
متى عاليه الدقه اطلقت من البحر نقطه
انتشار الفوج
30083 للطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه قرب
مدينه خملينسكي ومستودعا لذخيره المدفعيه
في مقاطعه
في محور كقضينا على نحو 250 عسكريا
اوكرانيا ودمرنا مركبات قتاليه ومدافع وفي
محوري
جنوبولوجيا بلغت الخسائر البشريه للعدو
نحو 70 عسكريا بين قتيل وشريح اثر استهداف
مواقعهم في اوغيلدار بجمهوريه دونيتسكا
الشعبيه
هذا وقالته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان نظامك
حسب تعبيرها يحضر الاستفزاز في احدى
المنشات ذات الخطوره الاشعاعيه واضافت
الدفاع الروسيه ان الغرض من الاستفزاز
واتهامه بشدها جبات عشوائيه مسعومه حسب
وصفها على منشات خطره الاشعاعي في
اوكرانيا
واشارت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى تسليم
عده حاويات تحتوي على مواد مشعه من اراضي
احدى الدول الاوروبيه الى اوكرانيا
متجاوزه التفتيش الجمركي في المقابل
قناتها الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
بدات مناورات واسعه النطاق لقوتها النوويه
الاستراتيجيه عشيه زياره الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن الى اوروبا
واضافت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه انه تم
التاكد من الاستعداد استعداد عناصر القوات
الروسيه المعنيه
باطلاق صواريخ باليستيه ارضيه وبحريه
وصواريخ كروس جويه واجراء فحص لنظام
السيطره القتاليه المركزيه للقوات الروسيه
وفق قولها